so for anybody in my audience who maybe, just
maybe was getting slightly complacent about
the November presidential election because
the polls just look so good for Joe Biden,
this is a red alert moment for you.
It should be a wakeup call to every one of
us that nothing is over.
This is going to be a huge fight.
Donald Trump could certainly win.
We could be facing four more years of a Trump
presidency, according to data provided to
Axios by, yes, the Trump campaign and the
RNC.
Republicans have more registered voters than
Democrats in some key states relative to 2016.
And I'll tell you, I've looked at the data
and it's a mess now as a pretext, not as a
pretext, as a as as a disclaimer.
I think better said they may be lying.
So I'm going to give you the data that Axios
was given by the Trump campaign and by the
RNC about voter registration.
They could be lying if they're lying.
Great.
Then we'll win by a lot.
Okay.
But if they're not lying, we need to take
this seriously.
And that's why this matters.
So the point here is.
All we can do because we don't know what the
truth is, is register every voter, convince
every voter to vote.
Make sure every vote is counted.
We've got to work on this at all levels.
But here is what was given to Axios by the
Trump campaign and the RNC compared to the
numbers that Axios was given by the Democratic
Party.
And if this is wrong.
Great.
But we have to, at least for now, assume that
this is accurate.
In Florida, the Democratic registration advantage
over Republicans was reduced by 87000 registered
voters since 2016.
Now think back to 2016.
Trump won Florida by one hundred and twelve
thousand votes.
If indeed now the party registration advantage
for Democrats has shrunk by nearly 90000 voters,
that is almost twice.
That is almost equivalent to that would almost
double Donald Trump's victory margin in 2016.
However, new registrations are favoring Democrats.
So what this means is you've had people who
move in and out of the state.
People who switch party, et cetera.
Among simply new registrations, Democrats
are winning.
But when you account for all of the other
changes in registration, Democrats have actually
fallen behind in Florida.
OK, Pennsylvania.
Pennsylvania is a state that Donald Trump
won by 44000 in 2016.
And the Democratic advantage in voter registration
has been reduced by one hundred and thirty
three thousand voters since 2016.
Again, Trump won by 44000 Democrats relative
to Republicans have lost one hundred and thirty
three thousand voters since 2016.
Important among new registrations.
Democrats have a 15 point advantage.
But again, because of moving deaths, a changing
of party, etc., the advantage has been reduced
by one hundred thirty three thousand.
In Arizona, Republicans have taken the advantage
in registered voters over Democrats in Iowa.
Republicans have taken advantage and registered
voters over Democrats.
And in North Carolina, the Democratic net
advantage has shrunk.
This is why overwhelming the vote is the necessary
action here.
If they're going to suppress the vote, well,
let's overwhelm the vote so that suppressing
it point o five point five or one percent
won't make a difference.
They win over.
They win over Democrats in terms of new registrations
or in terms of people who overwhelm the ballot
box.
Right.
It is truly the solution here to all of the
problems.
Now, another really important thing when you
look at new registrations and see the Democratic
advantage.
So, for example, imagine that in a certain
state, the Republicans were able to increase
their advantage in terms of party registration
by 100000.
But among new voters who were never previously
registered, Democrats registered more new
people.
My guess is that the new registrants are more
likely to vote because something got them
to register since the last election.
So maybe that's in our in our corner to our
advantage.
But you can't assume anything.
Now, there are a few funny caveats here, but
again, they shouldn't change our behavior.
Number one, some of the people changing registration
to the Republican Party, they might be doing
it in order to mess with the Republican Party.
We've seen people switch to the Democratic
Party to vote in the Democratic primary, even
though they have no intention of actually
voting for the Democrat in a general election.
We've seen it the other way.
We don't know for sure.
But it is possible that there are people switching
to Republican registration for a variety of
different reasons, many of which might not
mean they are necessarily voting for Trump
in November.
We don't know.
We can't do anything about it.
And again, we are evaluating registration
based on the data given to Axios by the Trump
campaign and the Republican Party.
They could be lying.
They lie all the time.
It wouldn't be hugely surprising if they were
lying.
But we can't know that right now and we won't
know it until the election.
If at all.
So we can't act on that basis.
All we can act on.
All that we should be motivated to do is to
keep going and assume nothing going into November.
Every single voter I apologize.
I know I say this a lot.
Every single voter should act as if their
vote could turn your state from one candidate
to the other.
That's how I will be voting in Massachusetts,
although certainly mathematically it's not
going to be
the case.